ça fait quoi que j'ai l1 loïc qu'est ce
qui est bon le monde le groupe ça
charles mais ça prend tout ça les luttes
par les mauvaises personnes pareil je
l'impression qu'avec le système tel
qu'il est c'est un petit pas
proportionnel encore donc mon vote elle
est relativement jeter aux poubelles et
l'élastique a regretté moment d'avoir
pour répéter et si on tire trop dessus
[Musique]
je me trouve ici entre les
circonscription de laurier-sainte-marie
et d'hochelaga à montréal
ces deux comtés où la course est très
serrée entre le bloc les libéraux et le
npd la victoire pourrait se jouer à
quelques voix
et pourtant si l'on en croit les
dernières élections le tiers des
électeurs ne devraient pas se déplacer
au bureau de vote
j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi je
sais pas si je veux pas parce que je
trouve que sa série once à promettre des
choses qui arrivent pour 11,7 ottawa
c'est tout le temps la même affaire je
voyais les quelqu'un puis dans un an ou
deux si on va parler conclut comme l'or
mais dans le passé est ce que vous avez
déjà voté va se passer mais j'écoutais
ce que le monde me disait d'aller voter
j'allais voter pour qu'est ce qu'ils
disaient parce qu'il ne sait que ça va
changer literie depuis bab avait
finalement ça change pro factory 10 des
jeux d'appareils à lire le portrait de
l'abstentionniste c'est davantage un
jeune qu'un vieux c'est davantage un
homme qu'une femme sauf après 65 ans à
s'inverse et il n'y a pas de grande
différence que l'on soit né au canada ou
à l'étranger
les promesses non tenues ça c'est la
première des choses
mais le cilice mains des politiciens ils
sont pas vraiment sincère quand on était
plus jeunes ont été blessés l'un des
partants mais en vieillissant
maintenant j'ai 75 ans alors c'est je me
rends compte que le vote c'est comme un
jeu parfois mais on ne gagne jamais
alors c'est toujours les politiciens qui
gagne
et puis c'est un peu décourageant selon
statistique canada les principales
raisons invoquées pour ne pas voter sont
le manque d'intérêt le manque de temps
le fait d'être à l'extérieur de la ville
l'incapacité de sang prix et le fait
d'être contre le processus électoral
je pense même de diversifier dans les
opinions des politiciens y a personne
qui vous convainc dans la liste qui vont
changer les choses qui confère sopo las
les citoyens et non pour eux pensent que
non j'ai vraiment sous-estimé à quel
point le sujet est tabou
il ya quand même un électeur sur trois
qui ne votent pas et pourtant beaucoup
beaucoup m'ont fait croire qu'il vote ou
alors ont refusé d'en parler
publiquement
moi quand j'ai eu mon premier enfant
quand j'étais étudiante et touche
battait pas ce que j'avais j'avais une
fois j'avais jamais une fois que je
pouvais apporter un changement puis je
trouvais qu'ils avaient déposé leurs
puits avait des goûts discours mais
justement je pense que le système est
tellement lourd qu'il faut quelque chose
de plus gros pour faire changer je pense
que c'est le peuple qui doit engendrer
ce mouvement le nom par un vote mais par
une solidarité
les membres des premières nations c'est
parmi ceux qui vote le moins et c'est
particulièrement vrai au québec qui a le
record au pays du faible taux de
participation des autochtones
par exemple dans la réserve de kahnawake
sur 8000 habitants il y en a que 56 qui
ont voté en 2015 là je m'en vais
rencontrer une association qui
s'impliquent pour faire voter les
bénéficiaires des aides sociales et les
itinérants qui généralement votre très
peu parce que si les politiciens
s'aperçoivent que si j'irai voter
ils vont s'occuper du fait qu'il ya des
jardins corporelle 2,65 d'aller au
bureau de la wii à l'icom sauf à la
ligne c'est pour ça que cette année un
bureau de vote à maison du père
expressément pour les gestionnaires mais
dans le quartier y en a pas mais on a
décidé d'aller avec leurs gammes au chpo
gêné d'être avec toi moi je vais aller
avec toi piqué rené-paul qui dise un mot
parce que moi je vais te dire je m'en
vais voir un père de famille qui voulait
s'abstenir de voter et qui a trouvé une
sorte de tour de passe passe
ça m'est venue un peu comme un flash je
ne saisis pas là attendez le ma fille
est allé à la manif sur l'écologie
récemment bon elle l'entend c'est par
parler de politique depuis qu'elle est
toute jeune elle participe aux
discussions de façon très éloquente
pour moi c'était naturel de me dire me
regarde je vais lui donner mon vote et
l'a14 à gérer et c'est elle qui va
prendre la décision son choix semble
être assez arrêté à ce stade ci après
deux débats mais je considérais que
c'était un geste tout à fait pédagogique
aussi pour elle de voter et donc moi je
ne lui enseigne pas l'abstention ce
n'est pas du tout l'objectif de ça c'est
vraiment au contraire qu'elles qu'elles
prennent possession ce geste citoyen à
ma place